hey guys welcome to another episode of
the Wednesday checkup there's a ton of
confusion and even some misinformation
out there about antibody tests so I
thought I'd set the record straight I'll
give you the scoop on what happens when
you're infected with Cova 19 how your
immune system reacts and what's the deal
with all these antibody tests should you
be running out to get one I'll answer
those questions and more starting now
[Music]
first things first let's talk about what
happens if you're infected with kovat 19
well first you have to be exposed to
someone who has covered 19 generally
that person will either COFF or sneeze
and expel respiratory droplets that then
have to make contact with your mucous
membranes
your mouth your nose your eyes sometimes
they'll land on your hand and then
you'll make contact with your face then
one of those viral particles will attach
itself to one of your cells it will then
make its way inside the cell and
actually start making copies of itself
using your own cellular machinery much
like a Xerox machine those infected
particles will start spreading
throughout your body mostly through the
upper and lower Airways that's where
kovat 19 seems to thrive that's when
your immune system kicks into high gear
and starts kicking that viruses but
however at the same time your immune
system starts making antibodies that's a
protein substance which actually gives
you lasting immunity against a virus
let's take chickenpox as an example if
you're yet to get the virus that causes
chickenpox your body fights it off
clears it and then it creates these
antibodies which serve as a lasting
immunity generally speaking chickenpox
is an illness that you get only once in
your life because of these antibodies
now let's move on and talk about the
testing for these antibodies generally
there are two types of tests qualitative
and quantitative qualitative tests
simply give us a yes-or-no answer
whether there's a presence of antibodies
at all for example if you've ever had a
strep swab or a nasal flu swab those are
qualitative tests positive or negative
only quantitative tests give us a
numerical value which establishes how
many antibodies are existing in our
blood these are generally higher end
tests that we actually have to send out
to a lab through a blood sample let's
summarize what we know now you get
infection with Cova 19 your immune
system kicks that spot clears it creates
a lasting immunity through a protein
substance known as an antibody we can
test for this antibody so shouldn't we
give this test to as many people as
possible so we can
send them out into the workforce because
they're protected not so fast
there's actually three problems with
these antibody tests I'm about to let
you know about problem number one is we
simply don't have enough information on
what to do with the results of these
tests for example let's say you go out
and get a qualitative test and you get a
positive result all that really tells us
is that you've had kovat 19:00 it
doesn't quite tell us about your level
of immunity because perhaps you had a
really mild case and your immune system
didn't build up enough antibodies to
protect you for the next time so the
solution might be let's get a
quantitative test well that's better and
you're gonna get a numerical value
telling us how many antibodies are
present
however we then need to rely on
reference ranges let me explain
reference ranges if you've ever gotten a
test to see if you're immune to measles
you get a numerical value back and then
we look at reference ranges to see if
it's above this value then you know the
person's immune if it falls in between
these two numbers their immunities
falling and they likely need another
booster shot and if it's below this
value they're definitely not immune and
they should get a booster ASAP with
kovat 19 whatever number we get is great
it might be accurate but we don't have
these reference ranges set up like we do
with measles of which we have decades
worth of research kovat 19 is a novel
virus these reference ranges take years
to develop so it's gonna take some time
until we know what's what and the final
point of all this is we don't know how
long the immunity lasts perhaps you do
have antibodies perhaps you are immune
for how long is that immunity gonna last
is it gonna be one week one month one
year or a lifetime you don't know that
information yet but we will soon the
second problem here is poor quality
tests there's over a hundred of these
tests on the market with only four of
them being FDA approved through an EU a
that's the emergency use authorization
it essentially allows companies with
limited evidence but still decent
evidence to show that the FDA their
products actually work think about the
dozens that are out there that are
really poor quality manufactured
god-knows-where and can be giving
questionable results problem number
three the false positive rate
look no test is perfect they all have a
margin of error and one of the examples
of that is a false positive rate where
it tells you you're positive but you're
actually not it's flat-out wrong and
some of the best tests have a 5% false
positive rate that sounds pretty good
but let's take this exam
into consideration picture yourself in a
town of a hundred people and five of
those people have had Koba 19 and
cleared it and the government wants to
use this antibody test to find out who
those five people are they're gonna give
the test to everybody and they're gonna
find out five people have had it but
because it has a five percent false
positive rates five other individuals
will also test positive even though
they've never had kovat 19 that makes
for a total of ten positive tests five
of which are accurate it means a 50
percent accuracy not so accurate because
the prevalence of the disease is quite
low but when the prevalence of the
disease goes up say 50 people have had
it in this town you have 50 people test
positive correctly five people test
positive incorrectly when you do the
math that over 90% accuracy you see how
the prevalence of an illness can affect
the accuracy of a test that false
positive rate really needs to be taken
into consideration when we use it in
areas with a low prevalence of kovat 19
all that goes to show that you as an
individual should not run out to get
tested for kovat 19 antibodies we just
don't yet know what to do with the
information we can't tell you if you're
100% immune even if you do test positive
the last thing we want you to do is
think you have a layer of security when
you truly do not what we can use this
information for is on a state on a
government level to see where kovat 19
is prevalent how many people have had
Cova 19 and not even known it what's the
true fatality rate of this virus and
which areas can we start loosening -
social restrictions in to get our
economy back these antibody test is
really important but it's not important
to us as individuals it's important to
us as a whole nation please if you have
any questions about these antibody tests
leave them down below I'm gonna be super
active in my comment section and check
out this video where I interviewed 100
doctors or check out this video where I
interviewed the man himself doctor foul
Qi